boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan Saki on
this is gonna be an interesting
conversation I'm gonna be talking about
my thoughts on being incarcerated for
four months back in 2012
most people don't know this about me so
I find this to be a very interesting
moment in my life when I get to go very
public about what happened in my life
and just unpack the nuance of recidivism
and of the corporate correctional
facilities that exist around the planet
and about the war on cannabis and about
just the intricacies of what actually
goes on inside of correctional
facilities so without further ado let's
just jump right into it thanks everyone
for tuning in really appreciate it so
let's go ahead and show you what
happened I was living in San Francisco
and I was I was heading out towards New
York at the time what was going on was I
was traveling from San Francisco to New
York in a car and I was going to
TechCrunch Disrupt which was in New York
that year and I was traveling via car
because I wanted to drop off a couple of
pounds of cannabis on the way I believe
it was about seven pounds of cannabis on
the way in South Dakota where I was born
and raised and so I found it very
interesting that you know the the
societal dynamics that exist where
California you can smoke cannabis on the
streets medicinally legal in Colorado in
Washington now it's completely legal for
recreational purposes it's just it's
just nuts that there
50% of the people that are incarcerated
every single year due to drug-related
offenses are there due to cannabis that
is [ __ ] stupid and needs to be solved
right away it's [ __ ] stupid and needs
to be solved right away it's a huge
waste of resources it's a huge waste of
creative potential and endeavoring in
our world people use cannabis for pain
they use it for food for eating better
they use it for their insomnia they use
it for all different types we have an
endocannabinoid system inside of our
bodies
enough is enough there's been a war on
cannabis the last 50 years and people
have worked really [ __ ] hard to make
sure that cannabis can be legal in the
United States and around the world so
anyway it's [ __ ] crazy that Sioux
Falls South Dakota has stupid laws in
comparison to California hella far
behind in comparison to Colorado in
Washington so just interesting [ __ ] like
that that I had to deal with so anyway
I'm driving I [ __ ] hit a deer in the
middle of the night classic you know got
to get that lesson every once in a while
and oh yeah by the way shout out to
these dope shirts are we in a computer
simulation boom boom boom you can find
them on our website simulation series
calm with the merch give it a shout and
give it a look share it with other
people over the holiday ask them these
really harrowing questions and to where
things that are very thought-provoking
all right back at it so so I hit a deer
and where did I hit the deer well of
course none other than Sturgis so here I
am in South Dakota you know you saw that
California is on the west New York's on
the east and here's South Dakota smack
dab in the middle of the United States
and so I'm trying traveling across and I
get I hit a deer right here on this
interstate i-90 middle of the night it
was like 3:00 a.m. so I hit a deer and I
hit a deer and then I'm driving with a
broken headlight
I was driving with two other people and
it was unfortunate because I wanted to
stop because our headlight went out and
wanted to stop and get a hotel but they
wanted to push
and get to Sioux Falls where we were
going anyway so I end up I end up
getting caught they they pull us over
for the headlight and then I have two
Latino people in the car with me
so inevitably that's a major reason why
we got we got stopped let's not joke
ourselves California rent rental car
with with yeah exactly so you you
everyone already knows what went down
and so yeah we refused we refused to let
the the cop search our car and then we
waited like an hour for a drug dog to
come and then you know the drug dog all
you have to do is [ __ ] pull the
collar of the drug dog you just got he's
got a Inc the collar of the drug dog and
drug dog will go or the drug dog can hit
every single damn car you gotta be hella
skeptical about [ __ ] like that
cuz a bunch of cars they search actually
don't have any drugs in them anyway so
I'm back at it so they so they search
the car they find the cannabis they set
us down they arrest us we go to jail in
we're in this [ __ ] jail here look at
this look at this jail so we're in the
middle of you know this is Sturgis this
is a Sturgis police station right here
what I'm what I'm you know highlighting
over and over again you can see and this
police station is very you know it's
it's a jail at the jail looks you know
the pods look like this this is where
this is where I'm staying I'm staying in
a place that looks like this here this
is an easy way to look like that so the
you know you're you're literally dudes
you're dudes that are stacked on top of
each other like two dudes two dudes two
dudes
two dudes two chicks two chicks two
chicks in their separate pod men and
women are separated in different pods in
this Jail it was I believe three pods
were men in one pod was women and each
pot at sixteen men eight on the top
floor eight on the bottom floor and four
bunks anyway
the crazy thing is when you when you get
in there it's nuts because you get in
there and you get a mug shot and you you
get fingerprinted and you get entered
into the correctional facility database
so you know everyone in the world can in
in the u.s. can know that you're you
know you're a criminal for cannabis
you know and I got thrown in the [ __ ]
pods with people that were in there for
pedophilia people that were there for
meth and heroin and and I'm there for
[ __ ] cannabis [ __ ] and so anyway nuts
that I had to deal with people there for
pedophilia and I'm sitting there with a
cannabis charge and so there's there's
there's obviously a lot more to talk
about but anyway getting put into the
system and being identified in that
sense and what that all means because
you need to know where you're at at all
times because you're now considered a
misdemeanor or a felony or and you got
to work to get [ __ ] off your record and
this is the system that you get put into
you know we were talking about that
episode earlier we were we were
mentioning on Takashi's episode we were
talking about a Khalif kalief Browder
boom right here kalief Browder who who
had that accused of stealing a backpack
and got incarcerated for three years in
new york and two years of solitary
confinement through that entire effed up
system so again just kalief Browder
scenario again and that's what six nines
pointing at to is the system is so
[ __ ] the recidivism is [ __ ] and it's
there to trap you and to try and in many
ways to try and trap you and many ways
is there to like make sure that people
that commit crimes that are pedophilia
acts when you are a pedophile you are
not able to be a repeat offender that's
why the jail is there fine we need that
but stop incarcerating people for
cannabis okay there's a big difference
between those two things I feel like we
need to zoom on that one that was pretty
intense
we need to zoom on that stop
incarcerated for cannabis she's using
the jails for [ __ ] like incarcerating
people that are pedophiles or that are
trying to give meth and heroin to little
kids on the streets you know those are
the things that need people need to be
incarcerated
for not cannabis he was [ __ ] weird
surrounding myself with people there
that were that were in those classes so
anyway this is what the center pot area
looks like so you know you get a hang
out in these in these little center pods
there's a [ __ ] there's a [ __ ] TV
and there's boardgames and there's all
this other kind of stuff and and and and
mm-hmm and there's a books and there's
an exercise area and all this stuff and
so you can only go to the exercise area
a certain amount of times or the book
once a week you can go to the library
and get books and that kind of stuff and
that's all really important because
that's how you keep your frickin sanity
while you're there having the freedom
taken away from you is the worst thing
in the world hate having freedom taken
away from you it's the worst thing in
the world God it sucks especially for
cannabis we stop risking so much be a
risk-taker with entrepreneurship or with
being artist or creative but don't take
risks with meth and heroin and child
molestation and domestic cases of
violence and gun violence stop [ __ ]
doing that [ __ ] it's not worth it so I
was in jail over my 21st birthday and I
think that's a very interesting point is
that I was 20 when I was incarcerated
and I got out right around the holidays
and I had turned exactly 21 over the
holiday and right before the holiday and
so I thought that was very interesting
that I spent my 21st birthday
incarcerated and that was a very
meaningful moment to me because I had
been spending so much of my [ __ ] 18
and 19 year old times in my first two
years of college at University of
Minnesota drinking excessively and so of
course I was doing other things like
participating in clubs and doing social
networking and and learning things and
being held accountable and working out
and other cool things losing 50 pounds
but at the same time I was drinking
excessively and smoking excessively and
I'm really [ __ ] happy that all of
this happened to me too
[ __ ] slap me in the face wake me up
and teach me to focus on building my
dreams into the world and this was a
major moment for me without going to
jail for four months I wouldn't be Who I
am today I won't have as much of a laser
focus
I wouldn't know so much about the
corporate correctional facilities and
how [ __ ] [ __ ] that system is and
in many ways and how it's important to
and how bad it is for people that with
cannabis violations so again it all has
taught me a lot all right back at it so
you know there are people there for
drunk driving and the people there for
drunk driving are a little bit more sane
in some ways the people there for drunk
driving they're there on maybe a first
DUI offense or even a second DUI offense
it's [ __ ] Rapid City area in South
Dakota western South Dakota so you know
when you're out out here in the middle
of a frickin and the in the middle of
frickin basically nowhere and very small
small communities of people of ten
thousand ten thousand maybe fifty
thousand people that it's it's easy for
you to drink and drive versus you know I
think uber just for just for those that
don't know I'm pretty sure
uber and lyft didn't make it to Sioux
Falls South Dakota and South Dakota I
don't even know if it's in Sturgis yet
but it's definitely in Sioux Falls South
Dakota they only got it out there like
last year like in 2016 2017 is when uber
and lyft made it to I don't even think
lyft is there yet I'm not sure don't
quote me on that maybe it's just Ober
anyway that gives you an idea about not
only are they behind on cannabis but
they're behind on technology in many
ways as well um but there are some small
business forefronts and stuff like that
and that's interesting but my point
being that you take a look at this of
course there's gonna be some some issues
that are I so anyway my point is is that
I'm hanging out with these with these
with these people that got our in there
for duis and whatnot and they're at
least business owners some of them own
their only construction companies and
truck driving companies and that kind of
stuff so when I'm talking to them I'm at
least able to socialize with them on a
business level about life and that was
that was kind of helpful um other things
that I did when I was incarcerated you
know the last thing you want to do when
your freedoms taken away from you is
like gain weight and be lazy and and all
and be angry and get into fights cuz we
get into fights you're [ __ ] you're
increasing your sentence it's even worse
so you got to learn how to stay calm in
jail you you literally become a man in
jail and there's a lot of quotes that
are out there from from young people
that have went to jail that say that it
makes you a man when you get into jail
and so I I did a couple things in there
one of the things that I did was I read
a fuckload so I read about trading
stocks I finally learned yes Mike Ovitz
Piroska not to speak in Russian but I
don't know how to write and read so I
learned how to write and read in Russian
I watched a lot of the stock market I
worked out a shitload I worked up
everyday lots of working out I read a
ridiculous amount of books I read so
many books every single week and so
anyway I did a lot of that and that
helped me stay sane in many ways and I
kept close social ties to people that
were saying there were [ __ ] weird
things like making like jailhouse
burritos which is when you take Doritos
that you can buy and you like crunch
them up with ramen and then you like
turn this Dorito ramen mixture you both
soak the ramen and water again you don't
have hot water so you're just soaking
ramen in cold water for a while and then
you've written and you then you you
strain you strain the ramen and then you
mix it together with the Doritos to make
a jailhouse burrito it's ridiculous and
you can put like mayo from your lunch on
it and stuff it's so weird and then
that's like that's food it's ridiculous
that that's food you can get like you
know there's commissary so you can put
money on your account or other people
can put money on your account you can
have someone visit you like once a month
or something like that it was ridiculous
oh yeah yeah without going into too much
depth about that obviously my mom
my uncle were not very happy with me
about this and they absolutely despised
me wanting to go back to California
after all this happened so however the
[ __ ] I managed to to hustle my ass back
out here is a [ __ ] miracle because
that's why I'm here today and I'm
building what I'm building and I have
the vision that I have otherwise Alan
and some other multiverse is still stuck
in South Dakota and in Alan and some
other multiverses like in Europe right
now or some [ __ ] because he wanted to go
travel so yeah crazy stuff without
getting too more into the nuance of that
there was crazy stuff happening like
there was this guy that would that would
tell me he was like he was like I think
his I think his name was Gerald I'm
pretty yeah that was his name Gerald and
Gerald would tell me he would be like he
that this this is this is a he would be
he would be like when you get out when
you get out of here put a file inside of
a puzzle box and like hide it between
the the the top of the box and the and
and we're just like slide it into where
the cardboard is so they won't know that
you're sending me a file and send me
that file and then what I'll do is I'll
break out of jail and then I'll tell you
where I hit an ATM I hit an ATM that I
stole I hit that ATM in the woods and
I'll tell you where that ATM is and I
was like damn this is some straight-up
out of a movie [ __ ] this is crazy stuff
like people are doing everything
possible to get out of there he was
going he was walking one time here let
me show you he was walking from he's
walking from right here he's walking
from the police station right here to
the clerk of courts right here so he's
walking just from the police station to
the clerk of course and so that's
because that's where they have the legal
cases so he has to like walk over there
in handcuffs alright but one time he
walks over there in handcuffs without
feet cops and he just Sprint's off and
he Sprint's off and he's trying to like
climb a fence over an interstate and
scape and he didn't get away
unfortunately and so but he wasn't a
violent offender either he wasn't a
violent offender I
don't remember what it was that he was
incarcerated for but it wasn't a violent
offense I'm pretty sure
anyway he he they they shackled his they
cuffed his legs next time so he also
couldn't run so that's what they do they
then go and cuff your leg so you can't
run away um so we had some crazy
scheduling stuff like you'd be woken up
in the mornings like lights would go off
at 11:00 ish night every night and they
would go on at 7:00 a.m. every morning
bright ass fluorescent lights and
remember you're sleeping in a bunch of
these in a bunch of these pod bunks with
other dudes and so you have to deal with
you know people farting people yelling
people moaning people screaming you know
people taking shits right inside of that
bathroom that's right next to where
everyone is sleeping on the pods and
that you have to smell the fecal matter
throughout the entire pod like I row to
go all the way as far away from the
bathrooms into the corner as possible to
get away from that smell and you never
know how good the air filtration system
is in there and there's 16 dudes in one
of these small ass pods and we're
sleeping on these on these bunks on top
of each other so you learn how to
[ __ ] respect people hella quick cuz
you're stacked on top of each other like
sardines and [ __ ] and then there's
another version of this you know here's
the other version where what you see
here is you see everyone has their own
individual cell so here every person
goes into their own room and sometimes
two people get stacked into each one of
these rooms you see them there on the on
the right side of the image and up floor
up as well and so that's different than
sleeping on the bunks there's these are
two different pods pod designs is what
they're called and so with this crazy
schedule they would they'd send you a
cleaning cart it'd be so ridiculous
every single day there'd be a cleaning
cart and the lady would come in the
corporate Corrections Facility officer
would come in and she would yell at 7:00
a.m. she'd be like cleaning car and she
would yell and wake everyone up and
everyone would have to you know wander
their way down to the clean car grab
things and it was like it's again it's a
sense of community and accountability in
the pod that everyone grabs [ __ ] and
cleans someone sweeps someone mops
someone wipes toilets someone
does organize this other [ __ ] in there
and so it's really important to clean in
there clean all the surfaces and stuff
that way you don't actually end up
getting totally sick while you're in
there too so so yeah there you know
you'd get fed and when you'd get fed
jail food which means you don't get a
choice so if they give you a slice of
bread with a piece of Bologna on it that
and an apple or if you're lucky you get
an apple or some potato chips or
whatever that that is what you get for
lunch and that's all you get and there's
no there's no nothing you can trade or
anything the best you can do is tell
someone I'll give you my bologna
sandwich for your Apple and then you can
make a trade like that and within the
people in your pod that's it that's it
it's crazy stuff and so I actually was
I'll tell you in a moment
the Athletics I'll tell you let me tell
you about the Flex there's this game
that you can play it's like once a day
ish yeah you can sign up to go play
athletics and there's a ping-pong and
then there's just a handball and that's
it you just get ping-pong and handball
and handball is you just like hit a
racquetball against the wall with your
hand and you played on two on two so
that was kind of interesting for a while
and you go to the library once a week
and get books and I think I would check
out like five books a week and smash
them and take notes on them still have
all my notes from jail
there's located somewhere in storage and
[ __ ] it's just crazy that you know one
time I'll open them up and read some
[ __ ] to you guys all right let's talk
about let's talk about when I served so
what ended up happening was in order for
me to actually serve for only a service
sentence of only four months what I
needed to do was serve and by serving
what that means is that you you work
with the correctional facility to
complete tasks within the facility to
earn good time and when you earn good
time you get out faster it was something
like for every eight hours you worked
you got a day off of your sentence or
something like that and so I would work
for eight hours a day and I got a
maybe for like two months I worked eight
hours a day so I got two months off my
like six months sentence and it got down
to four months that was about what it
was and I was just so freaking blessed
just so blessed because I didn't have to
spend those other two months in there
and I worked my ass off and I'll explain
what I did here let me show you what I
did so one of the things that I did was
that I you know here's the Meade County
Courthouse so this is you know where the
the trials are held right across from
the jail
damn I remember just a quick thought
along the way is that did you know that
judges are more likely to give you
probation or more lenient sentences
after lunch than before lunch
because before lunch they're hangry etc
it's just crazy that things like that
are recorded and understood it's like
everyone should have a 1:00 p.m. or 2:00
p.m. time if possible as many people as
possible should have that time because
then judges are they've eaten
it's just insane stuff like that so okay
back to this so okay so here's the poem
within the police station right here
there's a kitchen right so I would go
and I would I would get let out of you
know the doors are crazy the doors are
all locked doors I mean like they're
really tightly locked doors like this
room you have there's nowhere to okay
there's no way to get out of this room
right like the only way in this room is
through this locked door right here
where these where these dudes are in
their suits in the top left corner of
that image and my mouse cursors are
showing up it's or up here I'll zoom in
there so it's like right up there and
when you go through that door there's
another locked door behind that door and
they can only unlock those doors through
Mission Control which watches everybody
via cameras so there's cameras
everywhere they watch everyone all the
time and and yeah anyway and so you
can't get in and out so when you want to
go work in the kitchen which is what I
did I worked in the kitchen I'd go
through that door through like four more
doors and I'd get into the kitchen and
in the kitchen I would do things and
there's still more locked door so you
can't escape from the kitchen and anyway
I would do things like work with the
chef and I prepare the meals and that
means I prepare the breakfast I prepare
the lunch I prepare the dinner
and I would go and clean up all the
dishes from all of the pods through
rinsing him off putting him through the
dishwasher all that stuff
it was meditative it was very meditative
and it got me days off which was really
important and I bonded with the chef the
chef was cool and we played some cards
together and it was just fun learning
from him about poker and his life and
music and that kind of stuff and you
know and we augmented some of the
recipes cuz I like to cook and that was
where that was really fun but it was
crazy
we used a bucket of hydrogenated oil
like a bucket I mean a bucket like this
big like twice as big three times as big
as your head you opened it up and it was
just orange oil and that orange oil
would be used in everything he'd be used
in the vegetables and the meat should be
used in the in the dessert to be used in
everything to cook and there's more and
more stuff coming out about these
hydrogenated oils and how not you know
versus grass-fed butter from cows and
like what the difference is in health or
extra virgin olive oils and stuff like
that coconut oils etc all right working
in the kitchen was interesting and I did
another part of the I'll show you this
this last part of what I did turn credit
was I I ended up doing yard work so they
actually let me outside and that was
very nice of them to let me outside and
they trusted me after a period of time
to be let outside and they're they watch
you so closely they're like alright
we'll let you go do some yard work but
you know what when you try and run we're
gonna get you so fast and then we're
gonna add to your sentence so don't even
try and it would be so stupid to try and
so anyway I just worked my ass off for
them they would give me a lawnmower and
like here's an image of like wait a
second here so this is an image of the
jail right so here's all the you know
all these windows over here that's where
one of the pods this is one of the four
pods so you would see you know through
the and this might actually be yeah this
is either one or two of the pods but so
anyway that that was where iris
I did and then I they would give me a
lawnmower and they would and I would go
and mow this grass I'd move this grass
I'd mow I'd mow the grass you know over
here so that's this street view facing
this way you know from from this from
the street right above surge police
station and then I would mow I would mow
the grass over by Saint Martin's chapel
over here
I had mow the grass over here by the
Meade County Treasurer's Office I'd mow
all this grass and stuff and it was you
know it was interesting to mow the grass
around and um it was winter so I you
know there was a massive storm in
Sturgis so I was going up and shoveling
snow and picking up tree branches that
were dead like big massive tree branches
and taking them off site to a to a
Center where we could donate the pieces
of the trees for wood and stuff in
anyway it was just crazy actually being
able to work outside and I did that a
lot I had you know multiple layers of
coats and all that kind of stuff on so
anyway um hole and you know something
very interesting is that you know once
you're able to go out and be a little
more on your own time and they give you
that ability to go and you know and do
things on your own schedule you can kind
of you can kind of take more of your
time like if you want you can get
through things really fast which is good
you know but you hopefully they'll have
another thing for you to do because if
you go through it a little slower you
could spend the whole day outside
instead of only four hours outside
hustling so I would try and do things a
little bit slower and more meditatively
and then I would I would spend quite a
bit of time inside of bathrooms so I
could be alone I would just go and hide
inside of bathrooms at like the Meade
County Treasurer right here and I would
you know right here Meade County
Treasurer and I would just go and hide
inside of bathrooms so that I could have
time alone sometimes I'd masturbate in
there because you know what happens when
you spend all that time in the pod you
just never have a time for any privacy
at all
so guys are like you know masturbating
in the shower and stuff and that's like
the best they get you know you get two
showers you get into two bathrooms two
bathrooms have a shower in them and then
two toilets in those areas so that's it
for 16 dudes so it was it was nuts again
so it was a huge learning and growing
experience in my life and I'm you know
and I'm very very grateful for it you
know it's hard for people to understand
that they're like oh how are you
grateful for going to jail and I think
it's really important to understand why
to be grateful for something like going
to jail because there's so much to learn
about the incarceration systems about
things like the war on cannabis how over
fifty percent of people that get
incarcerated for drugs are there due to
cannabis related crimes and that needs
to [ __ ] end as soon as possible
shitload of lost creativity and so and a
shitload of lost resources on that and
these jails are crumbling in many ways
in their infrastructure this jail here
at Sturgis this Meade County one was
actually somewhat decent and they had
more decent food and they had more
decent structure but there's a lot of
jails that are [ __ ] crumbling across
the United States and so again
overpopulated jails and there's a lot to
learn and I'm happy that I'm able to
share the story with you all and how and
what it means to you know have spent
time in there because now I can
empathize better with other people that
I've actually spent time in there and I
think that's a really important bridge
to have because when you're just so
disconnected from people of low SES or
people that have that are dealing drugs
to in order to survive
then you don't you're never in their
shoes ever and you don't know what it's
like to be in jail ever so the more that
you can empathize the better we can
bridge the conversation and see it from
all perspectives you see a six I see a
nine now you see a nine I see a six
right so we see it from all the
perspectives from white from black from
man from women from low SES to high yes
from a grandpa to a ten-year-old etc you
have to see this issue from all these
different perspectives for someone
that's been busted who hasn't been
busted etc so thanks everyone for tuning
in to this episode on the four months
that I spent in jail I really appreciate
you guys tuning in and give me your
thoughts in the comments below I'd love
to hear from you I'd love to hear some
of the potential solutions we have for
some of the things that are going on in
the system and getting less of of
corruption and greed and recidivism and
focusing more on peace and prosperity
and love and under
standing and I think that is definitely
going to be the future as xxx dentists
you once said that this generation will
be understood I love you all thank you
very much
and just let's do it let's build the
future together and let's manifest their
destinies into the world I love you all
I love you all and this is Alan sake on
the hosts of cimelia a simulation series
check us out simulation series calm all
the links are in the bio join us on
patreon
join us on cryptocurrency donations we
need your help with scaling our efforts
are being invited to interview people
around the world and we can't fund those
interviews that really prominent people
it'd be a lot of fun to do it people
like the world's leaders in artificial
intelligence like max take mark out and
boss and wants us to go there really
soon and we need to fund these things so
help us out everyone all right that's it
much love everyone I will see you soon
peace and love thank you